yeah pulley dan the Hall of Famer Johnny
Bench on the line field Johnny good to
talk to you where do you stand on these
world empires are we gonna keep this
thing dude I'm it's I'm sure with
technology it can work and everything
else I just um I'm not big on it I like
our umpires some of them are not not so
good but I still like our umpires and I
just think it's hard to major a stance
and get a direct line they'll have to do
it from the pitcher's mound pitching
rubber to get the exact box and there
the rectangle so no I'm not I'm not 100%
light at all what's your stance I
haven't I wasn't able to listen or heard
Joe the earlier but I didn't I'm okay
with it if if they adjust to the hitter
I just think that they need to speed up
the game a little bit I don't think that
the player should be adapting to an
umpire strike zone it feels like
baseball should have its own strike zone
it'd be like watching a tennis match and
say you know the the umpire has his own
dimensions there on the court like you
know it should right it should be this
this is what the strike zone is but then
all of a sudden you got Joe West or Eric
Gregg and they go no it's a ball what or
that's a strike and I think that that's
what's crazy
that we've allowed them to have this
much power and they have their own
interpretation of a strike zone this is
somebody gets thrown out the other day
arguing about the robocall or some some
minor league throw you out now I know do
you argue they have an umpire what's
what's he doing he's in a lawn chair
he's there to say ballers strike they
send the message down to him well the
umpire so he can throw you out but what
it what is it with David
got thrown out like seven or eight times
this year and he's never won an argument
he's never going to win an argument you
know and I guess he feels good about it
what's the best argument you ever heard
when you were behind the plate well if
you remember back in the World Series in
1971 with blade the Orioles and Ken
Burkhart great great umpire I love the
guy he was just great and everything
else and it was they when Bernie carbo
scored and and and Kenny haddock say is
back to the play and Elrod didn't even
come close to to touch him and Sparky
was out there but he didn't touch him
Kenny he didn't cut him I saw it I saw
it clearly Sparky I saw it grueling and
one of the bit one of the best was when
yo when as Casey Stengel went out Dennis
Ryback was pitching I did and in case he
goes out
and Tom's Gorman's telling me the story
the other umpire and he says and they're
arguing and and you know case he's
trying to get the ball and Danny won't
give it to him
and so finally Tom goes out says what's
going on case he was he won't give me
the ball well give him the ball he said
no no no I'm not giving the ball give
him the ball he said no no I got this
guy out last time and Sparky said yeah
but I mean Casey said yeah but it's the
same inning oh hey how was a Hall of
Fame weekend good I just sent Fritzi a
picture I I take my camera into the art
dinner and I started as a few years ago
where I take the picture because nobody
had ever had a picture of the
presentation when the Commissioner gives
the player is black or his ring so I
started going in and then after that I
convinced them that you know it's such a
great affair these guys never have any
you know evidence or anything else and a
proof of what they really got received
so I started doing well they have a Hall
of Fame photographer Milo in there and
so he now takes the pictures but when he
was gone and I walked over I walked over
to each of the players and I end with
Lee and and Mike and Edgar and Mariano
and and Errol and I said put your ring
on and they'd never you know they just
it was still in a box and I made all of
them put the ring on and so we
really cooled I just had big Richie a
picture of Mike wearing his ring and I
have all of the all of them holding the
Rings that was really kind of a special
moment and and I go around take pictures
of the guys you know I got a picture
with Carlton Randy Johnson and Koufax
pretty pretty good life why did it tell
us why did it take this long for
somebody to be 100% on the balance well
I think was the old school you know the
old guard said that you know the guys
nobody's ever been a hundred percent of
papers and all those guys are now 2
percent and there was just the old guys
that voted and you know and now it's
such a logistical thing an analytic
thing that everybody now just says you
know there's no way that this guy is
hitting shoulders have both at it and
they'll do it and you know I think it's
just a matter of you know he's a hundred
percent I mean he was he was amazing my
goodness I mean he stood head and
shoulders above everybody and
honest-to-goodness just you know some
you would you would crucify the guys
that didn't vote for him I mean you'd
have to do that and and I think they
take a little more credence in the fact
that it's not so much the old guard that
didn't get voted in a hundred percent
but it's actually the guys now that
really deserve it
hey Johnny it's always great to hear
from you thanks for joining us yeah you
know what I have a couple more chemo
visits and then I gotta get off this
damn steamed vegetable diet and and once
I get off that then hopefully things
will be a little better
thank you buddy I think I appreciate you
asking that's the great Johnny Bench
joining us on the program for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]